benvenuti solito storico sono in italia
da oggi avete chiesto in tantissimi di
vedere i video in cui le macchine
schiacciano le cose che sono cosi
schiacciano slide piacciono scommesse ci
avete detto che sono bellissimi da
vedere anche i suoni che fanno smr
quindi siamo super curiosi di vederli
assieme o poi e poi poi alla fine del
video potete scriverci nei commenti qual
è quello che vi è piaciuto di più quindi
qual è la cosa schiacciata che mi è
piaciuta differenza quindi tenere
veramente poi nei commenti mettete il
times ha così vediamo qual è la cosa che
mi piace rimane schiacciata a quell'ente
se volete vedere altre reazioni strane
mettetevi comodi preti boxscore ecc
abarth allora io sono infatti d'accordo
ma sono liquida dentro tipo come la
mamma velocissimo
cos'è questo come 100 malati ha giovato
né bellissimo parco ghiaccio
credo sia la phone 7 wow rumore dei
gestiti era pazzesco
allora questa cosa mi fa giulie
un'altra spugna di quelle flora francesi
queste possono quelli la vostro fitto la
lavatrice una parte perché così rivalta
andato a vedere anche il suono questo
che sono il bubble si solidificano o
quasi uno degli slide dentro forse dice
a casa va raggiunto pure a fatica questa
macchina delle storie gigantesca perché
sarà la cena
troppo bello e caldo
mario tutta pizzi con l'auto un esclusi
proprio è troppo vivo dove caramelle con
la quale abbiamo visto prima essere la
settimana buona tipo che c'è un pochino
due volte della macchina l'italia supera
srl di nuovo sempre le stesse bollire le
single queste cose
si intrecciano dell'acqua una
bottiglietta queste scuole forse è
comunque disponibile ma so che è un
congelato su scritto wow sono spaghetti
un grosso cacciavite non mi consente di
cota montanino sono scappate cosa sono
no adesso palloncino per l'acqua e la
mostarda
[Musica]
poi vanno velocissimi sembra tipo 1
strisce slow rising no a bonn
cos'è questo carbone deboli per noi
domani è entrata non ho capito questa
cosa di cioccolato nero o ghiaccio altri
bat bombe sante che c'è chi è fuori una
birra wow
questo pone la terza foto quello sotto
dei loro sola esistenza attive niente
ricotta un cetriolo sanno pure i celeron
mese preferito per il suono si fanno
impazzire finito perché buoni e uovo no
[Applauso]
per questo scrive che infatti vanno
troppo grosso non si capisce niente
ora esce la frittata di pasta meno dei
cannelloni di coloro che quella specie
di schiuma che serve da coibentante è
massimo ma anche un bel sole che fa
metodio che corre rincorre spaghetti si
è molto rilassante per fare la sfoglia
una spugna
stamattina l'acqua per farlo mi sembra
una bat fondo the decision
il bari ha fatto solo diritti ma perché
sono un rumore più soffusa
l'arte attiva no ancora no ma no a erano
vuote comunque mi sto rilassando un
sacco funzionano davvero questi suoni
sono davvero mr
che bello che qualcosa è cambiato
come dire se scoppia nuovamente la
bottiglia d'acqua di esplode gesti che
sono un sacco di fatto abbiamo visto
prima gol e infine cosa sono pezzi
costano la mamma
sarà il motore infatti come sanno a fare
in modo che non si sente motore della
macchina molto cazzo l'uomo anche vs il
pil solamente quelli che vanno più di
moda sono questo spugne e quasi a
gennaio
ma questa divertente
[Applauso]
c'è scritto sogni cangemi schiacciati
non è soltanto perché è la prima volta
avviata la macchina che si ferma ma che
ben colori o benissimo sommesso tipo il
patatina solo finta
[Applauso]
che sono meravigliato intento di vento
questa curva
se si ha dentro uno slide di tivoli
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'anguria lavoro e colorata fuori di
stile
mi è dispiaciuto la stretta
ma così si rompe no oddio wow che cosa
sono
for this giganti hanno lasciato troppo
tempo nell'acqua come sentimento nella
norma come fa la ruota a resistere poi
chiodi non bucarsi è perché forse è
incredibile abbiamo un bacino vuoto sarà
lo sloveno che gheddafi ha vissuto due
[Applauso]
addio ma tutto il fatto di far mattine
vita vera e temporalmente sera è una
purea l'ha dipinta di rosso
chissà perché la dipinge di rosso polo
di loro è un computer e televisore
distrutte cosa c'è un collare nel
profilo wow
[Musica]
palla alta resistenza che video
bellissimo vestito bellissimo ma è
un'altra auguri ma perché viola questa
buriana lorenzo la liguria come
sottometterli rosai vele tra l'anguria
ragazzi questo la compilation facci
sapere fare quello che ti è piaciuta di
più a me mi che siete un sacco quello
delle barre bond l'olimpia senza qui
sono che fa io mi sembra che mi ha
scioccato di più quello era quello con i
chiodi della mattina mi piace a me è
piaciuto invece piacevano quelli là con
gli spaghetti dove c'erano gli speriamo
che faceva un sacco di ogni hunter degli
spaghetti
sì mi ha scioccato invece l'anguria con
lo slide voi potete realtà il top di
quello che vi è piaciuto di più e ora vi
lasciamo a quattro cartellini su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
nuovi video challenge radio divertenti
cliccate su quello che preferite